oh mein gott freundlich war mal wieder
unter www unterwegs luca im internet ich
will mich nämlich draußen unterwegs auf
jeden fall habe ich dort einen artikel
gefunden über die dümmsten dialoge und
das habe ich dann ausgeübt weil youtube
letters hat irgendwie jedes video von
mir altersbeschränkung macht auf jeden
fall habe ich mir jetzt einige dieser
dialoge rausgepickt und habe ein paar
sachen zensiert ein paar sachen einfach
weggeschnitten die uninteressant fahren
um euch zu zeigen wie früher irgendwie
eingeleitet wurden
die erste szene hier spielt am
abendbrottisch einer familie die mutter
hat ein telegramm bekommen
bis jetzt noch alles in ordnung
familienoberhaupt kommen nur nach hause
um meine sachen zu holen finanzielle
versorgung gesichert
fußballfan die frau hat hier also ein
telegramm bekommen von ihrem ehemann
also dem vater der beiden kinder die
dort am tisch sitzen und der sagt hey
ich komme dem nächsten oder warum meine
sachen holen ohne finanzielle versorgung
ist gesichert aber ich bin jetzt erstmal
weg ich scheide mich von dir aber wir
schauen jetzt mal wie die frau darauf
reagiert finanzielle versorgung
gesichert und gestellt dass ich mal der
versorgung vor das einzige um das sie
sich sorgen macht ist ihre versorgung
ich hasse das mit dem aus blieb aber ich
will nicht dass das video wieder 18
geschaltet wird die mutter fragt sich
wer sie denn in zukunft mal schauen ob
die kinder darauf eine antwort wissen
bruderherz ich denke ein braver sohn
kümmert sich um die mutter nicht also
die tochter hat der frau und sagt jetzt
hey mein bruder könnte das ja übernehmen
der bruder also der sohn von der frau
darf man sich diese schlangen vorher mal
betrachten ich krieg die krise freude
das ist nicht wahr ich glaube jeder sohn
würde in so einer absurden situation
etwas sagen hey was ist denn sucht den
neuen mekka oder keine ahnung was war
das
ja auch in fest aber er fragt ob er sich
seine mutter den mal genauer anschauen
kann freuen dass es falsch war um sich
überhaupt auf meinem stuhl
[Musik]
ich muss unbedingt auf den lettischen
seit einer halben stunde also wir sehen
hier zu beginnen ein mädchen was
irgendwie wahrscheinlich unterwegs waren
seien dagegen die sie nicht kennt und
sie muss ganz ganz dringend auf toilette
klingelt dementsprechend an irgendeiner
haus zu bauen man auf macht und sie
fragt ihn der nächsten zeit habe ich
jetzt mal einfach rausgeschnitten weil
das eigentlich irrelevant für die
storyline ist auf jeden fall lässt er
sie dann mit ein ohne sie sucht die
toilette findet die toilette allerdings
nicht und dann geschieht das hier auf
einmal sitzt dieser typ in seiner
badewanne und bietet die mädel an in die
wange zu küssen
das super regisseur arbeit
ich weiß gibt es ein elektriker ist oder
keine ahnung aber er hat eine super
schauspielerische leistung dort
abgegeben
er wollte wohl irgendwie in dem haushalt
dort irgendwas reparieren und daneben
sitzt irgend so ein junges mädchen und
sie erkundigt sich jetzt nach dem
wohlbefinden des herrn also sie fragt
diesen mist dann nun wort ist wohnt ist
keine ahnung dass jetzt auf englisch
oder auf deutsch sein soll aber jetzt
meine damen und herren könnt ihr noch
einiges lernen und zwar wird sie jetzt
versuchen diese personen wiederzubeleben
über die mund zu mund beatmung
ich singe grad auf das niveau mal hab
ich frag mich halt die ganze zeit also
okay natürlich auf der einen seite ist
das alles hier vor sehr langer zeit
gedreht worden aber auf der anderen
seite waren die menschen doch früher
nicht so dumm dass sie denken dass das
irgendwie gut oder nice seien keine
ahnung auf jeden fall machen wir es
weiter mit dem nächsten dialog und zwar
ist dort der fall dass eine ein mädel
besuch ihrem opa und dieses kamerateam
begleitet die beiden weil die beiden so
eine tolle beziehung zueinander haben
herr ranicki ist noch sehr rüstig für
seine 63 jahre und zu verbringen die
beiden eine nette zeit zusammen also ihr
seht schon da ist das mädel die besucher
hat ihren opa und die beiden verbringen
eine schöne zeit zusammen mein opa ist
total lieb er erzählt mir immer so
komische geschichten manchmal spielen
wir auch total verrückte spiele ich
amüsiere mich bei meinem opa also ihr
opa erzählt ihr komische geschichten die
spielen einige komische spiele
miteinander also sie organisiert sich
einfach köstlich bei ihrem opa nach
außen haben die beiden ein tolles
verhältnis was aber spielt sich hinter
den verschlossenen türen
das frage ich mich auch liebes
kamerateam widerlegten wir uns mit
versteckter kamera auf die lauer nach
kurzer zeit bestätigte sich unsere
vermutung die vermutung bestätigt sich
mal schon was jetzt passiert gegen ein
taschengeld bietet nach den ihren opa
dienste an
nein doch nein doch nein doch was geht
da ab leute her ich verstehe das nicht
also natürlich ja klar habe ich schon
gesagt das ist alles ein bisschen hält
er das und alles irgendwie früher
gemacht aber wer kommt denn auf die idee
dass das irgendwie ein gutes drehbuch
sei
[Musik]
in diesem film hier haben zwei damen
etwas geklaut in einem supermarkt und
der besitzer hat das ganze gemerkt
dementsprechend spricht er die beiden
jetzt darauf an irgendwie da ihr bezahlt
dass dort wirklich nicht glaubwürdig
ausbilden es war klar es war einfach
klar er wird sie fragen hey was ist
jetzt los hier was ist deine sache habe
die ausrede sein die beiden dänen
ausrede nicht aber wie könnte anders
klären
nämlich mit napa tierischer papier
[Musik]
hi
hier sehen wir eine ganz normale
druckerei wo du eine person gerade
arbeitet nämlich ein junges mädchen und
da kommt einen schub an und sagt hallo
ich bin von der unternehmensberatung man
schauen was er jetzt ihr anbieten wird
genau damit machst du heute geld
eine anständige druckerei die
unternehmensberatung mit der dame und
sie sagt brandstätter bereit
das ist das ist kino im nächsten dialog
blende ich euch einfach mal
ungeschnitten so ein weil diese ganze
szene hatte ich weiß jetzt dass
irgendwie noch im gras anderem was
größeren endet oder so ob das einfach
nur lustige schlimm ist aber auf jeden
fall bei dem artikel auch mit der bayer
hat den schatz
schaut euch einfach mal an wir haben
wieder bier
er liegt auf irgendeiner party mit dem
girl und diese daten rumknutschen und
sohn sagt er liebt sie über alles andere
und dann kommt sein kollege rein sagt
die haben doch wieder der check up ist
auch genau so sollte man das machen was
suchst du noch nie von anprobieren die
wollte ist ja wohl klar kommt ala
ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen er ist
eine feuerwehrstation und dieser typ
kommt dabei und sieht dieses mädel die
dagegen die gerade keine ahnung was
anprobiert in eine uniform oder so und
sie sagt sie wollte einfach mal
anprobieren ich mein welches mädel
mattes länder nicht welches mädel ist
denn nicht schon mal zur feuerwehr
eingebrochen und wollte schon immer auf
jeden fall hat er sie dann auf frischer
tat ertappt und schreibt nun alarm und
mal schauen was jetzt die kollegen
machen
sie holen bett also wenn bei mir alle
einbrechen würde dann würde ich auch
direkten bett holen
das ist so macht das die polizei auf
aber meine damen und herren kommen wir
jetzt zu dem dialog dem so ziemlich
jeder eigentlich kennt kennen sollte
weil es einfach ein übelste smim
geworden ist es das komplett überall
bekannt es ist leute machen sich darüber
lustig aber es ist wirklich kunst
das ist die leicht bekleidete dame hat
probleme mit dem stromkasten und hat
sich dann einen recht unter geholt und
der stellt sich jetzt erst mal folgende
frage eine stinknormale konversationen
die auch zwischen mir und einem
elektriker auftreten könnte er fragt
sich hey warum liegt von dem stromkasten
eigentlich stroh und ich frage ihn
nochmals pop mit maske auf das ist doch
der denkt liegt jetzt eine scheiße aus
das war für sie allerdings auch von
wieder meine damen und herren ich habe
einfach in einem artikel diese
meisterwerke des films gefunden und
april gedacht hey komm ich will ihr euch
nicht vorenthalten
ich habe jetzt alles möglich irgendwie
zensiert also wahrscheinlich war es ein
bisschen langweilig aber ich hab ich den
artikel unten verlinkt falls ihr euch
noch unzensiert anhören anschauen möchte
bei das ist ja das ist ja einfach
wirklich ein meisterwerk des films ich
wollte einfach nicht dass dieses video
hier aber 18 geschaltet wird deswegen
habe ich das ganze gemacht wenn euch das
video allerdings trotzdem gefallen da
will ich mich sehr über einen leid von
euch freunde schreiben die kommentare ob
ihr die tage wieder einen neuen format
sehen wollte oder ob ich irgendwas
anderes spielen sondern irgendwelche
video ideen was ich machen soll haus in
die kommentare
und jetzt will ich sagen meine damen und
herren kommt das outro glas wasser ziel
vom bio das war's jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder
einen schock aus schenkungen jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und
managen abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]